oui
mais
alors qu'on pense bertrand deckers
j'entre crachements pudding alors c'est
donald trump ses cheveux jaunes ses
costumes du tout ses bottes de cowboy
qui se permet de donner des leçons et
des conseils au sexe que j'aime pas
beaucoup un ici je sais que j'ai connu
quand même très décarie et mégane se
sont ils sont restés duc et duchesse de
sussex et aussi à la reine d'angleterre
qui se permet aussi de donner des
conseils à la reine 70 en carrière quand
même qu'elle va fêter au mois de juin si
elle irait ses lamentations décrypte un
tout petit peu le journaliste que vous
voyez là c'est pire si mauritania pierce
monial il a été viré il présentait good
morning britannique et de grands le
grand rendez vous matinal en angleterre
il a été viré parce qu'il a eu des
paroles lui aussi très douteuse son père
médiane en fait sa couleur de peau
notamment et il donne cette fameuse
interview pour un lancement d'une
nouvelle chaîne de télé qui s'appelle
talk une youth et talk news appartient à
rupert murdoch et c'est une chaîne
d'infos people donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
parlent des sexes et qu'il y ait une
icône à ce point d'image il est déteste
vraiment où c'est pour le non mais des
tests sur tout mais gagne qui rappelons
le a vraiment créé par contre donald
trump dans la campagne oui à la salle
hilare il ya
deux ans l'artisan vous auriez dû le
retirer tout leur titre parce que toute
petite part en tête si elle a retiré le
titre de le prédicat ce qu'on appelle le
prédicat ils ne sont plus altesse royale
il demeure encore duc et duchesse de ce
sex baron et bahreïn sur ce qu'elle la
comté conteste de domme barton il paraît
que d'un fixe le rapport aux prix
laissant barre aussi qu'ils avaient
c'est vrai ça non il nous explique
l'arrière repris du tout netflix au
contraire est en train de dire on vous
les a donnés ils ont dit les en trois
paiements ils ont reçu les le premier
cas maintenant briques si vous voulez
toucher les 66 qui restent vous allez
enfin devoir nous donner des billes donc
est ce qu ils ont fait passer
catastrophique il ya quinze jours ils se
sont pointés au château de windsor avec
une équipe de télé elle n'explique et il
souhaitait vraiment être introduit au
sein même du château et de la reine plus
précisément ça s'est très très mal passé
donc sans et wario c'est que les
articles qu'ils étaient en train de
feuilleter les rallidés en fait c'est
bon ça j'aurais regardé buckingham tirer
est ce qu'on les a laissés rentrer ou
pas non absolument pas a laissé rentrer
ils sont qui sont prises baisse et ce
chez royal est à la cour carrée du
château de baffles bien fait pour leurs
troupes
[Rires]
alors oui qu'est-ce qu'ils vont tourner
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tourné et bat
donc ils ont quand même on les fois
arrivé à windsor ça a été repris en
moyenne sur
je peux vous dire en tout cas c'est que
je vous assure quasiment certain qu'ils
vont être présent au jubilé pour
l'instant eu disons ne pas encore trop
sur par rapport à notre service de foot
et moi je me dis qu'ils y seront tout
simplement a
expliqué m maintenant qu'ils sont plus
princes et princesses c'est eux qui
casquent bas personnellement leur
sécurité dont il ya un mois c'est voilà
cinq gardes du corps cagnard ton et dont
l'ancien garde du corps de barack obama
c'est de me semble-t-il c'est ça voilà
la tire
toujours juste et en fait ça leur coûte
une petite fortune absolument cinq
gardes du corps en permanence à marcoux
travers scotland yard ne peut plus
intervenir dans la sécurité lorsqu'ils
sont sur le territoire anglais et la
reine souhaiterait évidemment ardemment
qu'il soit présent au mois de juin où on
va célébrer le jubilé durant cinq jours
de fête incroyable pour l'instant ils
nous disent on n'est pas encore certain
que nous pourrons être présent puisque
le problème de la sécurité n'est pas
réglé mais moi je vous dis qu'ils seront
présents au balcon et que c'est cela la
scène finale du nul en terre de l'état
comme dirait cyril et la question
disposé que tout le monde se pose c'est
est-ce qu'ils sont reflètent ils sont
300 palettes est née avec la
questionnaire que plus d'argent que vous
êtes l'êtes vous n'avez plus qu'un garde
du corps eux n'ont été pas mal être
c'est vraiment un bon départ
en lisant un train de vie qui est
dispendieux et qu'on sait combien
d'enfants de vieillards par mois c'est
énorme
on estime que rien que les cinq gardes
du corps au jour par jour
quotidiennement on est dans les 40 min
58 quotidiens avec netflix six ont déjà
utilisé un homme ayant eu mensuel non
non on quotidienne quotidiennement tous
les jours non plus long entre ce que mes
baskets mais je me croise quand même car
tout le haut rhône a fait un million
deux de sécurité par mois raconte c'est
énorme il ferait regard des délais les
chiffres exacts sans acheter un fromage
pour acheter une baguette et un fromage
de tokyo pour les gardes du corps
avaient beaucoup peut-être énorme et ça
l'a dit
république donc le c'est à dire mais on
va changer de métier direct un
garde du corps vous oui et alors
attention à l'accident à bascule assez
sa tête
[Applaudissements]